la parole est à monsieur pierre charon
pour le groupe ump
la baby ce monsieur le président
monsieur ministre sur président de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur le
texte que nous examinons en deuxième
lecture aujourd'hui a été examiné en
première lecture ici même il ya déjà un
an alors même que nous avons sur un
certain consensus
on peut le voir à travers les différents
orateurs sur la reconnaissance du vote
blanc
pour toutes les raisons que nous avions
évoqués en première lecture
il est nécessaire d'adopter ce texte
sans plus attendre le vote blanc est
l'expression d'un point de vue notamment
celui de l'insatisfaction au regard de
l'offre politique proposé le vote blanc
est bien l'expression d'une opinion et
même d'un message politique
je pense que nous devons lire le vote
blanc comme un thermomètre de la
démocratie et non comme une vague
fantaisie des lecteurs considérant le
choix de certains électeurs qui ne se
reconnaissent pas dans l'offre politique
y compris celle des extrêmes ou qui ne
croient plus aux messages politiques ils
reçoivent et on ressent de la détresse
nous devons être capable de l'entendre
pour mieux encore porter un projet qui
puisse répondre aux préoccupations du
plus grand nombre de citoyens au-delà
des modification formelle visant à
rendre applicable le dispositif aux
élections municipales
les modifications issues de la deuxième
lecture à l'assemblée nationale porte
sur deux points le cas des enveloppes
vides
la question est de savoir si elles
devraient être comptabilisées comme vote
blanc ou comme votes nuls et l'entrée en
vigueur du texte la question était de
savoir s'il doit être applicable aux
élections municipales de 2014
le cas des enveloppes vides ce point
questionne sur le périmètre du vote
blanc et du vote nul le sénat avait
souhaité rester prudent sur le périmètre
du vol blanc afin de distinguer
l'intention politique
blanc de l'erreur ou la maladresse votre
nul pour cela il avait exclu le cas de
l' enveloppe vide et obliger ainsi les
lecteurs à produire une action positive
prévoir un bulletin blanc pour éviter
tout amalgame
pour autant l'objectif de la proposition
de loi est d'accorder un vérité par dont
il a connu une véritable reconnaissance
du vote blanc
dans ce cas il est contradictoire de
complexifier l'accès au scrutin à ceux
qui souhaitent recourir au vote blanc ce
qui est le cas si on oblige des
électeurs à prévoir un bulletin blanc
qui n'est pas fournie par les autorités
organisatrices
a contrario si le butin est fournie par
les autorités organisatrices
on tombe dans l'excès inverse et on
consacre le vote blanc comme une offre
politique à part entière au même titre
que les candidatures
il convient donc de trouver un juste
équilibre entre reconnaissance effective
du vote blanc et nécessité de ne pas
décourager l'engagement politique qui
s'exprime à travers une candidature la
reconnaissance des enveloppes vides en
tant que vote blanc pourrait donc
permettre de concilier la volonté de
donner une pleine valeur au vote blanc
sans pour autant basculer dans
l'incitation à y recourir
ce qui serait le cas si un bulletin
blanc fournis par les autorités
organisatrices figurait à la même place
que les bulletins relatifs aux
candidatures en second point l'entrée en
vigueur de ce texte en première lecture
le sénat avait souhaité rendre la
proposition de loi applicable aux
prochaines élections municipales de 2014
en revanche l'assemblée nationale
souhaite que le texte entre en vigueur
le 1er avril 2014
si la brièveté de l'échéance est
invoquée pour justifier le report de
l'entrée en vigueur du texte après les
municipales de 2014
on ne peut pas ignorer la petite
manoeuvre politique visant à sauver les
apparences de ce qui s'annonce être un
vote test pour le gouvernement
mes chers collègues sortons d hypocrisie
et des postures nous pourrions encore
débattre justement de ces questions et
affiner les choses mais le temps passe
et des échéances électorales majeures
approche
l'objectif de mise en oeuvre rapide de
cette réforme doit nous conduire à voter
ce texte pour éviter un nouveau report
il serait incompris les électeurs je
vous remercie merci la parole